joe biden s'est réservée la dernière
touche à une montée en puissance
progressive de la tonalité diplomatiques
américaines ces derniers jours c'est
donc au président américain qu'il est
revenue la charge de menacer ni plus ni
moins le kremlin de menacer la russie et
l'armée russe de lourdes pertes en cas
d'offensive sur l'ukraine et ce mercredi
joe biden affichait sa quasi certitude
qu'il y aurait bien une offensive peu
importe les démentis de moscou le
pentagone alimente régulièrement la
maison blanche renseignements et le
dernier chiffre en date n'indique non
pas un retrait partiel des troupes
russes massés à la frontière de
l'ukraine comme cela a pu être évoqué au
cours des dernières semaines mais bel et
bien un renforcement qui fait passer le
contingent de 100 milles à cent trente
mille hommes on notera au passage
d'ailleurs que la toon la tonalité des
déclarations d' anthony blinken le chef
de la diplomatie américaine est moins
agressive que celle du président le
département d'état encourage encore et
toujours sergueï lavrov et vladimir
poutine a privilégié la sortie de crise
par le biais diplomatique notons aussi
donc qu au moment d'entrer dans sa
deuxième année de mandat joe biden
envisage clairement et distinctement un
conflit armé avec la russie